[Music]
thanks to all of you who signed on for
this which is my first our studio
webinar I'm going to talk about the
package read Excel which I've recently
done a maintenance release on and I want
to talk a little bit about our sticker
for read Excel so our studio and any
other sort of package producing entities
have started to create these PEX
stickers so that you can show your love
for packages and the one we made for
read Excel is supposed to capture that
really special feeling you get when you
find out that the data you need is
actually in Excel so hopefully if you
want one of these
you can find one of us in person at some
meeting and maybe we'll have them you
could put them on your laptop to show
your suffering so read Excel is a
package that finds itself inside a
larger group of packages which we're
calling the tidy verse and this I
believe is still a subset of the tidy
verse but the idea of the tidy verse is
to take a collection of packages and
make sure that they operate with a
common philosophy and a really similar
interface so that it's easy to transfer
expertise from one package to the other
it's easy to move objects from one
package to the mother and so read Excel
is the tidy vers solution for getting
data out of Excel spreadsheets and into
our you see the URL for the website up
there it's still I'd call it sort of
under development but we're adding more
and more packages to it and then we're
you know increasingly adding content on
the tidy verse itself so it's certainly
absolutely worth visiting at this point
and you can expect that to increase in
sort of quality and coverage over time
another really important sort of
documentation I would say for the tidy
verse is there's a recent book although
it's been online for a quite a while by
Hadley Wickham and Garrett grown-woman
both of our studio called are for data
science and in some sense it's it's a
meta manual for the tidy verse or in
certain you will certainly see the tidy
verse packages working in their natural
environment and working in in concert
with each other throughout that book so
it's a really good resource and you can
buy a physical book or if you go to this
URL that I'm showing there it's has
always been developed in the open and
you can always access the content online
for free and below I have a graphic that
we see in a lot of talks by Hadley and
other people who develop or work in the
tidy verse this meant to depict a
typical data science and data analysis
workflow and read Excel is one of the
packages we have to deal with that very
first step which is importing data out
of a spreadsheet and getting it into our
in a favorable form to sort of fly
through the rest of this cycle at least
as easily as possible
a little bit of history on read Excel so
it was first released on cram in April
of 2015 and that release was written
entirely by Hadley and then about a year
later it had a patch release which I
think was just triggered by a need to
update for compatibility with a package
so that didn't have a lot of changes in
it and so then it got its first major
maintenance release about a month ago
which is when I took over as the new
maintainer and we moved the version up
to one I feel like it is pretty feature
complete and we squashed lots of bugs
and added a few new features which I
will talk about today and in case you
want to install it in the background
while I chatter on
little bit more so one way to get read
Excel installed on your computer is to
install the entire tidy verse so we now
have a package called tidy verse which
is kind of different from the concept of
the tidy verse it's a meta package that
will up install the whole set of
packages on your computer or you could
install read Excel all by itself so just
install that packages read Excel then
either way but you must load read Excel
individually there is you can actually
call library tidy verse and it will load
a subset of the tidy verse packages that
are kind of called the core and read
Excel is not part of that core because
you wouldn't need it in almost every
analysis it's only when you have a
spreadsheet so you will always have to
load it explicitly on its own so I
promised in my abstract to give a little
bit of the landscape of our packages
that read Excel lives in and the reason
I wanted to do that as I figure anyone
who's willing to spend an hour with us
talking about Excel must have some
slightly non-trivial need to read Excel
files and it's kind of interesting just
to know where the packages fit in and
like why some packages are harder to use
than others and what the different
features are so there's a huge set of
packages that read Excel files because
this has been an important area for a
very long time obviously so read Excel
might actually be the most recent entry
into this group open Excel X open Excel
SX is also fairly recent and it uses a
lot of the same stuff under the hood is
read Excel some packages that have been
around much longer our Excel Connect
xlsx and G data are ODBC and there are
many more packages some of which I
linked to actually from the readme a
read Excel itself for dealing with very
awkward data but so these are the ones
probably that I consider
most comparable in terms of when people
look up packages what they are
considering using so when you're
thinking about where it is read excel it
in and which of these packages are
relevant to me I think there's you know
at least three things you need to
consider
so one there's two broad classes of
Excel files and if unless someone's been
evil you'll be able to identify them
from their file extension so dot XLS are
the older Excel files in our
documentation we call them legacy files
and those are files from Excel up to
about 2007 but there's plenty of systems
today that are still producing dot XLS
files and in fact Excel itself is still
quite content to produce these files and
then the more modern file format is xlsx
and that's what you're going to get by
default coming out of Excel now and
again there's lots of third-party tools
that'll be writing these sorts of files
second question to ask is not about the
files but it's about the r package and
there's sort of two main categories of
our packages there are those that are
self contained versus the ones that have
an external dependency and I'll talk
about this just for a second so neither
of these file formats is something that
you want to parse by hand all by
yourself from the ground up so all of
the packages that read Excel files are
standing on the shoulders of others and
have some sort of dependency where we're
bringing in an existing library to parse
the file and it turns out that the most
comprehensive package for doing that is
as a Java system called the Apache Pio I
and so the packages that wrap Java have
great functionality in the sense that
you can almost say if Excel can read
this file this package can read it
because of all the accumulated
conventional wisdom in Apache Pio I and
so that's why
when you're writing an Excel reading
package for art it's very tempting to
use Java because you can take advantage
of this pretty amazing resource and
likewise there are some sort of Perl
scripts that have been around for a long
time that have a lot of smarts about
reading excel files and so we've taken
another approach and read Excel which is
to bake everything you need into the
package and then the third huge
component to think about is whether the
package you're using is oriented towards
bringing in a rectangular piece of data
so a data frame usually or is it more
focused on or capable of focusing on
individual cells and formatting so
here's where read excel comes out on all
of these points it is able to read XLS
and xlsx it is self-contained so once
you get it installed which should be
relatively trivial and definitely let us
know if it is not it will just work that
you don't need to configure an external
dependency in the right place for it to
work and it is explicitly focused on
bringing in a rectangle of data so it is
not a package that's going to reveal
formatting for you whereas some of those
others will so hopefully this gives you
a sense of where excel fits in I'm going
to show you this is a screenshot of one
of the Excel workbooks that ships with
the package because I like to use it a
lot in examples and it's something I
created recently and I guess it's a bit
morbid actually it's a spreadsheet it
felt you know we talked about a lot of
it feels like a lot of very famous
beloved people died recently around
Christmas or and so I actually made a
spreadsheet of recent deaths and it's
also more to show how we import data
with different column types and whatnot
so we're going to look at this sheet in
a moment live in the IDE but the thing I
want you to notice here is I try to make
it sort of a typical spreadsheet
where people have written some stuff at
the top and some stuff at the bottom
which actually brings me to my next poll
I'll come out to them just a second and
so read Excel is really focused on
helping you find or identify this data
rectangle and bringing just that data
rectangle in so that's indicated by this
yellow box so read excel is highly
focused on a data rectangle as opposed
to absorbing an entire spreadsheet and
all of its glory so this would be a good
time to launch the second poll of three
and so I don't know how that works and
okay you've got it up there okay so how
would you describe the typical excel
file that you import and you do have to
pick just one of these are they always
neat there's a data rectangle in the
upper left hand corner are they always
super awkward it feels like you're
reading data from absolutely anywhere in
the street or I see a mix of both so
have at that yeah so this has been
typical of my experience as well that
you see a bit of both but actually I'm
happy for you people it looks like neat
data rectangles still are a bit more
prevalent than awkward data in any case
alright thanks
the second point I want to make is that
the IDE that our studio ide has a really
nice little helper for getting Excel
files loaded into our so this is a
screen capture of that and we will show
that to you live and this is me
importing that same spreadsheet and you
can see a lot of the same data there in
the data preview and below and the
import options we've exposed some of the
most useful arguments for the functions
the main function of the package read
Excel and you can see a preview of the
code you would need to write to get that
so we will talk soon about the our
Studio IDE and the excel helper
you'll see that demonstrated and here's
a screenshot right after I've brought
that dataset in and we have a data frame
in our it's a table which is a special
flavor of data frame that is arguably
the strongest theme that runs throughout
the tidy verse so it prints very nicely
which we're enjoying right here so you
see we've got a table that we brought in
from Excel it has 10 rows it has 6
variables and the thing I really want
you to focus on is notice the types of
the variables that's one of the nice
features of table printing that you get
to see these types so name and
profession our character vectors age is
double or numeric has kids is a logical
vector true or false date of birth is a
POSIX ET date time and the code right
above there actually brought this data
set in and you can see that I didn't
have to specify any of those column
types read Excel guessed them and in
this case guess them correctly correctly
so I would describe read excels column
typing is pretty groovy when it works
you can also take explicit control which
we'll show in the demo the last thing I
want to point out before we switch to
the IDE so here I'm importing that same
data set it turns out it has two
worksheets or two tabs and they have the
same structure
they all have name age has kids all
those same variables and so one thing I
want to point out before we're all done
here is that read excel can be used
quite nicely in workflows and so what
I'm showing here is I'm reading that
workbook but I'm reading both sheets and
I'm gluing them together row wise to get
one big data frame that has the data
from the first sheet and the second
sheet and has a variable indicating
which sheet it came from
and this seems to me to be an under
under known underutilized feature when
the map D F function I've circled there
is not from read Excel it's from /
another member of the tidy verse but so
I do really want to make sure that
people are aware of these iterative
workflows so that you have solutions
when you have multiple worksheets in a
workbook or you have multiple workbooks
that you need to import so there are
going to be some demonstrations of
workflows and this is actually where I
want to ask my last poll which is I'm
curious to know if most people use Excel
in an artisanal way sorry I read Excel
in an artisanal way or